hello everyone and welcome to another
video in our puzzle solving series
and in this video we are going to
venture into the depths of the unknown
uh we are going to try our hand on
puzzles that are even more complex than
the puzzles we solved in the last video
as you can see i have set the rating
range of these puzzles to be 2500 to
2900 so we are going to be solving not
just advanced level puzzles but really
what i would call master level puzzles
puzzles that you should be doing if your
rating is i would say over two thousand
now even
do not be scared by the number 2900
these puzzles are still doable
and as with the previous videos i'm
going to try my very very best to
explain uh the solving process some of
them i might even get wrong uh because
some of these problems really do get
challenging
uh so if you're ready to accompany me on
the journey please stay
and once again i'll be trying to share
general pieces of advice and if you are
newer to chess i would highly recommend
having a board with you so you can
actually follow
follow the variations there will
definitely be
long and convoluted uh lines here but
that's part of the fun okay let's
let's jump right in
okay so first position
um we have an interesting situation now
white is down a piece we've got two
bishops black's got two bishops and
black as a knight
we are actually in check i kind of like
problems where
you start by being in check
and um
well we're gonna have to respond to the
check regardless of what else we observe
but
um let's have a quick look at the whole
board just to see what we're dealing
with here
i think that white's only big asset is
this big attack down the h file so
hypothetically if we could deal with uh
the threats on our king
black might have a very hard time
stopping simply the threat of queen
takes h7 checkmate that pawn on h7
really can't be defended easily
black can play knight f6 but then you
would presumably just take the knight
with a pawn
so
the the win condition here seems to be
dealing with um
these this check and trying to keep our
king in one piece so the question is do
we go king a1 do we go king c1 or do we
sacrifice our bishop for the pawn well i
think bishop takes c2 can be ruled out
immediately because then after queen
takes c2 check
the king moves aside and that queen can
travel from c2 to g6 take that pawn and
defend against any possible threats
okay the natural move is king a1 but
what worries me about that move
is that after black takes on d1
we have to
take back with our brook and that means
our queen and rook are no longer doubled
on the h file black can simply play f
takes g6
and defend against all the threats on
the queen side so we
on the king side so we have to keep our
rook on h1 and i think that means we
have to go king c1 because after c takes
d1
king takes d1 black doesn't have any
good checks
and white has succeeded in keeping both
of our pieces
on the h file so
pretty sure it's king c1 chess.com has a
pretty good sense of humor they make a
bishop but that doesn't change anything
we still want to take it
okay and that's it queen c1 check that's
obviously just a
a way to prolong the game bishop takes
c1 2700 problem solved this is one of
those puzzles that's that doesn't test
your ability to calculate far but rather
your ability to to find a
counter-intuitive move because who wants
to put the king right under the shadow
of the queen of the rook and yet if you
know what you're doing
if you know that the goal is to leave
the rook on h1 at all costs then the
puzzle becomes pretty easy
because there's just no other choice
okay
so moving on
we've got another puzzle here with white
to move okay so it looks like white is
quite clearly i would say hunting for
checkmate
and we've got we're again we're down a
piece but we've got three major pieces
all in very close proximity to black's
game so at first sight it may seem that
queen g5
just leads to a simple ladder mate the
king steps onto the h file
and then the rook comes out to h6 or h4
with me but it's always a red flag if
you're solving these complex problems
and you know you think the solution is
elementary you should always stop to
stop and think twice and indeed after
queen g5 check if you look carefully
you'll see that black has knight g6
covering the check when black's king is
entirely unscathed
so it appears that we need to look at
other ways to approach the black king
okay so one logical
step we might take is is say well if the
knight is is gone from the board
then queen g5 check would work
unfortunately
that kind of logic only goes so far
because if you take the knight with the
rook then black recaptures with the rook
and the initial position where you had a
check on g5 is no longer
is no longer applicable queen g5 is
obviously absurd the rook just takes it
and you can give a check on h6 but then
the king steps back to g8 so taking the
night with a rook the medicine is kind
of worse than the cure
medicine is kind of worse than the
disease there
so are there any other checks we ruled
out queen g5 and rook takes c5 well that
really only leaves queen age six check
so what happens after queen h6 king g8
well
one thing we can observe in that
resulting position
is that we kind of have to play with
checks because
black is threatening a background check
of his own followed by queen g1 and i
think allowing that would
you know is is very unfeasible i feel
like white's king will get checkmated
there so after queen h6 king g8 it makes
sense to look at other checks
okay so there's rook g4
but then simply knight takes g4
there's queen g5 so queen h6 king g8 and
now queen g5
how have the circumstances changed as a
result of the black game being on g8
rather than g7 well if you look
carefully you'll see that after black
blocks with the knight knight on g6 we
can actually capture that knight with
our rook because black's king is no
longer controlling the g6 square so
after queen h6 king g8 queen g5
knight g6 rook takes g6
f takes g6 white is able to take that
pawn with the queen
force the king into the corner and now
we still have one of our rooks remaining
which can swing to h4 that's not
strictly speaking checkmate black can
still block with his rook but after rook
takes h5 black is going to have to give
up the queen
and white is going to have an extra
queen for a rook
so i think the key here is to start with
this this check on h6 force the king
back and then return to g5 with the
devastating attack boom
boom now we capture the knight this is
the main difference
queen takes g6 this is a relatively
straightforward problem what do we learn
from it well one of the keys to solving
these tactical puzzles is
uh to understand that just because a
move doesn't work under one set of
circumstances doesn't mean it doesn't
work under another so
if you've ruled out a move like queen g5
do not what you shouldn't do is kind of
make a mental note to yourself and say
queen g5 never works because in chess
the smallest difference a repositioning
of the opposing king for example as we
have here
is going to radically change
uh the the sort of set of circumstances
and you have to revisit moves all the
time move doesn't work in one position
you give a preliminary check and you
look at that move again maybe something
has changed and
you don't even have to necessarily
understand what has changed if you
simply expose yourself to that position
uh you might kind of get lucky and and
figure it out
okay
so
interesting problem here this is an
opening white has just captured a rook
on a8
but very clearly we have two pieces
aimed at f2 so we can take we can take
that pawn now what do we want to take it
with this is a clear decision making
exercise queen or bishop and neither of
those moves is immediate checkmate
because after let's say queen takes f2
um
white goes king up to d2
and i think in order to solve this this
exercise it really helps to know uh
mating patterns
and and mating patterns can be worked on
you can you can work work on them on
chess.com without a good knowledge of of
mating patterns basic mating patterns it
can be a little bit overwhelming to
consider all of the sequences of checks
that you have so i think the solution is
to take with a queen
and after white plays king d2 to drop
the queen
back to f4 with check
there's a twofold idea if the king keeps
walking up to c3
you've got this common idea queen b4
checkmate
and if the if if the king walks back to
e1
then the reason we have put our queen on
f4 is th so that it controls the d2
escape square then we drop our bishop on
f2 and that is actually mate because the
d2 square is controlled
now can we start with bishop takes f2
and after king d2 then go queen f4 well
the answer to that is no
i don't think so at least the reason is
because the king escapes to c3
and that b4 square which was a potential
mating square is no longer under the
control of the bishop because the bishop
is now on f2 so in a certain sense
bishop takes f2 prematurely commits the
placement of the bishop we want to take
with the queen
go queen f4 check and depending on where
the king goes um either the bishop does
the heavy lifting or the queen okay e3
one last ring call
um
we need to be very careful here actually
because
if we take with a bishop
then
white goes king c3
and we're stuck with a familiar problem
um there's no queen before mate
but if we take with the queen
and the king goes up to c3
aha and that's the key we take with the
the queen the king goes up to c3
we drop the queen back to d4 with check
okay i'm essentially what i want is to
get the same position just without this
pawn on e3
the queen takes e3
uh king c3 queen d4
queen d4 now if king b3 then we still
have this mating square on p4
if the king goes back to d2
then all we need to do is go back to f4
that is the golden square we get the
same position as we have now without the
pawn being on e3 and white doesn't have
any more pieces or pawns to put in
black's way it's going to be checkmate
boom
boom
back to f4
and king e1 queen f2 is finally made
that was a really pretty puzzle i really
really like that puzzle because it
really it helps you work on on your
understanding of chess geometry and
mating patterns and those kinds of
things really often need to be worked on
with brute force you solve a hundred of
these problems and you start identifying
these mating patterns more easily
okay let's see if we can squeeze in two
more
first position
okay
so
it's taking me a second to adjust my
eyes to this black is technically up in
exchange
in return for one two three
four five six
seven pounds now that situation arises
exceedingly seldom
uh in
real chess you you normally do not get
uh seven puns as compensation for the
exchange it's very rare for one side to
have seven pawns on the other side to
have none but that doesn't really matter
let's try to solve the puzzle
now
it's crazy to imagine that black and
when this game the only thing that i
really notice is that white's king is
confined to the corner
so the first try that that we could
attempt here is king g3 and that would
create a very powerful checkmate threat
on e1
white's king is unable to escape the
corner in time white's rook is unable to
assist
in the defense so is that it is king g3
the solution well no
white can block the e file with the move
bishop before you should always consider
these moves that kind of block the file
bishop before
and this rook has been essentially
incapacitated
but how has bishop before changed the
position well it's opened up the other
rook so what we could try here is king
g3
bishop e4
rook takes f7
and that renews the mate threat now it
threatens made on f1
the problem there is that white can go
king g1
defends the f1 square
and all of the avenues toward white's
king have essentially been closed down
in that position
so
is there anything that that we could do
is there any way that we could alter the
position well let's think
king g3
bishop e4 what we normally want to do is
follow the advice i shared in the
previous video which is go back to the
last moment at which you had a choice i
think a lot of people would reject king
g3 but that might not be the problem
maybe it's just that we're not seeing
the correct approach after bishop e4
so
i think the the target position is one
where
one of the rooks threatens a mate on the
back rank so king g3 bishop before the
only reason that rook takes f7 doesn't
work
it's not because the idea is wrong it's
because this is the worst square to try
to get to because it's the only square
that can be protected by white's king
after king g3 bishop before
if there is a way
for one of these rooks to threaten
checkmate on any other square
white would have no way to defend
because the rook is sort of locked
locked in
by by white's own pawn
so
king g3 bishop before can we open any
new files
well what about rook takes c4 that comes
to mind maybe we can sacrifice one of
the rooks in order to open the d file
pawn takes c4 is forced
and what if we then bring the other rook
over to d8
and even though we are down seven pawns
we're threatening checkmate on d1 and in
that case i don't believe that white has
the capacity to stop it
white can actually go b8 equals queen
check
because that king's gonna be on g3 but
even that doesn't help because white
takes or black takes that with the rook
and then we're threatening rook b one
checkmate and white's rook is still
incapable of doing anything about it
because the bishop is now gone from the
board
and i think that that's the solution we
start with king g3
now we play the brazen rook takes c4
sacrificing an exchange when we're down
seven pawns but the idea was to open the
open the default okay again v8 equals
bishop we've seen that twice now they've
underpromoted to a bishop uh rook takes
b rook b7 this is all fluff uh we don't
even care if white promotes to a queen
because none of these squares are
defended twice if they were if there was
let's say a knight
on on e3
then after rook takes b7 f8 queen rook
b1
white would be able to block with the
knight or block with a queen so here
it's important to establish that no such
move is possible we take the queen
problem solved okay
i think this one's going to be
uh actually it's it's only been 15
minutes so we can probably fit a couple
more exercises in
all right i think this one's
actually
very straightforward it's just a matter
of
of not going for the initially tempting
move and just you know approaching this
logically
now it's a situation where both queens
are hanging black's queen is under fire
as is white so we could if we want to
take white's queen here and what would
happen then well if we take white's
queen
white takes our queen we recapture that
pawn
and what's the pawn count white's got
five pawns and i think black has seven
okay so black is gonna be up two pawns
in that situation but it's not the end
of the story after knight takes h5 gf
knight takes f6 white can throw in a
check on e7
and then white can recapture that pawn
on c6 slicing the material lead down to
one pawn nothing not that impressive
right
so as i've shared before any situation
where you have both queens hanging
what you need to look for are two types
of moves the first is
whether you can move your queen away
with check the logic being that while
your opponent has to respond to that
check on the next move you essentially
take your opponent's queen the second
type of move barring you know
there's no there's no check is a
desperado sacrifice and a desperado just
means you have a situation where you're
going to lose your queen anyway so you
might as well give up your queen for
as much as you can get
all right so in this situation if we
could take something out with our queen
and then on the next move take white's
queen then we would end up let's say up
a piece or up whatever it is we took
with our queen is that possible here
well we can't really take the pawn that
doesn't make sense because then our
opponent's queen escapes
uh escapes being attacked the funny
thing is we we could take the pawn and
then go knight h3 and recover the queen
but that's not that impressive again
because of knight e7
um black actually gets checkmated there
so but what about queen takes f5 i think
we can just take the knight
and if white takes back then we take
white's queen and we're gonna be up at
night and after queen takes f5 if white
moves the queen
then we move our queen and we're up a
piece queen takes f5 knight takes h5
easy
okay moving right along
all right so we've got
another end game here
and not a lot of pieces have been left
on the board
queen bishop and pawn against queen
knight and pawn
and what do i notice immediately about
the
the nature of the past pawns well i
noticed that black's past pawn is
blockaded by the king it's not going
anywhere
white's pawn is what's called an outside
pass pawn it's literally
as far removed as possible from black's
king which means that if we transition
into a pawn end game
it is very likely that black is going to
be unable to catch this pawn so that
could be an early target can we force a
transition into
uh some sort of a pawn end game well
why would i think that we'd be able to
do that well i noticed that the queen
the king and the knight are aligned on
the same diagonal and yes we do have a
dark squared bishop so the move bishop
d4 immediately comes to mind
but
in an end game like this you always have
to watch your own king a move that's not
a check may allow your opponent to take
over the initiative and that's what
happens here queen d4
sorry bishop d4 there's queen a3 check
and at the very least black has a very
annoying series of checks but if you
look even further you'll see that after
king drops back to c2 black can simply
go queen d3 check and that's a fork
against the king of the bishop black is
just winning
but bishop d4 is not the only way that i
see
of inducing a transition to an end game
what we can do is we can do this in a
slightly fancier way we can take on e5
first and after queen takes e5 then we
can go bishop d4
uh re-skewering black's queen and king
okay now is that the end of the story
takes takes bishop d4 we are going to
get our desired pawn end game but the
one thing we have to check is whether
black's king will be able to catch the
pawn
now after queen takes e5 queen takes e5
bishop d4 black is best served to
immediately bring the king to f6
trying not to waste any tempe giving up
the queen in an undesirable way
so after king f6
the queen takes e5 queen takes c5 bishop
d4 king f6 okay we take black's queen
king takes e5 let's calculate a5
king d6 a6 king c7 a7 king b7 oh no
black catches the pun
so in that line black was able to catch
the pawn black will make a draw
queen takes e5 queen takes e5 bishop d4
king f6 here i have to introduce one
very important trick which is that
sometimes people
rush to take a pinned piece as long as
you are pinning that piece whether it's
a queen or a giraffe or zebra or
whatever it is
you don't technically have to take the
piece until your opponent has physically
escaped the pin or attacked the piece
that's doing the pinning neither which
is the case here so we can actually
streamline the process after takes takes
bishop d4 king f6
we could go a5 first and only after king
e6 do we take black's queen essentially
forcing black to waste another move
taking that bishop of the king going in
the wrong direction and then we're able
to promote the pawn we have the extra
tempo that we need we go a6
and the pawn promotes so i think we can
safely go for queen takes c5 as long as
we don't take the queen we go a5 here a5
bishop b5 okay so this is interesting
black is heading toward the corner
anyway
using the very important rule and i
think a lot of you watching the video
are probably familiar with this if you
have a bishop and you have a corner pawn
but the promotion square is opposite to
the color of the bishop
that is a draw provided that black can
get the king in the general vicinity of
the corner okay that was a mouthful but
you can find that and you can find
videos about it
i might talk about that separately the
long story short
is for example if for example white
takes on c4 with the king
and black ghost king c6 and then king b7
that is an unwinnable position it will
be impossible to get the king out of the
corner
so does that mean this position is drawn
well no what we have to do is find a way
at all costs to stop the black king from
getting to the corner
i think it makes sense to start with a6
right that's just a sensible move if the
king heads back to c8 then all we have
to do is let's say just take black spawn
on c4 black is in zug's wong because the
b8 square is covered by the bishop the
king will have to move back out toward
the center allowing the pawn to promote
now what about
a6 king c6 that seems more
logical heading to b6
well can we cut the king off there well
we sure can a6 king c6 we can go bishop
d4
but then the king's gonna double back to
c7
and head to b8
and if we give a check on e5 then black
plays king b6 and the king is
is just going to win the pawn so let's
try that again a6 king c6 bishop d4
king c7 aha can we defend that b8 square
in any other way we can
and this is a familiar idea to me you
can go bishop a7
yes the bishop is blocking the pawn but
the point here is not to rush with
pushing the pawn the point is to bar the
black king from getting to the corner so
bishop a7
and that's it the king can knight can
neither access b8 nor b7 nor even b6
it's fully cut off from the b file and
what we do then is we just take the pawn
on c4 and push black's king out with our
own king so this is what that's going to
look like let's do it a6 bishop d4 and
bishop a7
very pretty way to cut off the king the
puzzle ends here
but after and i can't make moves but
after king c6 you can just follow in
your head king takes c4
king comes back to c7 we keep
approaching with our king in opposition
and once the king hits c8 we go king c6
and then black has to head the other
direction king d8 and then we can move
our bishop and push the pawn that was a
long puzzle but it was a pretty easy one
to observe first we set ourselves a goal
we want to transition the game into a
pawn end game why because we have an
outside pass pawn we think about it we
put our tactical hats on we see queen
takes e5 then we realize that we don't
need to rush because the king is still
pinned we can save a crucial tempo by
going a5 and then we find a way to use
our bishop to cut the king off
pretty simple but obviously a lot of
steps all right let's tackle one final
problem
and it's going to be one where we have
two far advanced past pawns
and black has a couple past pawns of his
own but they seem a little bit less
scary than ours
all right so it it appears to me that
the goal is going to be to promote our
past fonts right and a logical way to
start is to go a6
a6 rook a7 seems to be forced
and then it appears that we win with the
move d7 distracting the rook from a7 and
then we push the a pawn and black has to
give up the rook for the pawn is that it
well let's be careful a6 or k7 d7 wait a
second black doesn't need to take that
pawn black can take it with the king
black and go king e7 and then capture
the pawn on his terms where the rook
remains on a7 to blockade the apoc
so we go back to the last moment which
we had a choice a6 rook a7
now this is a
a classic position where i think tunnel
vision happens a lot
it's very easy to just focus on the two
past pawns and whether they can be
pushed and not see the forest for the
trees after a6 or k7 the b file has
gotten opened
and i'm also noticing that the black
king is surprisingly weak on f8 it
cannot go to e7 so a back rank mate is
possible if you get your rook to the
back rank here so after a6 rook a7 could
we try the move rook b2
that seems like a pretty scary move for
black to face because
rook b8 mate is threatened and if the
black king heads toward the center with
king e8
then we can still give a check on b8
after king d7 the rook drops back to b7
check forcing the rook trade and in that
resulting position notice how the d6
pawn is preventing the black king from
approaching the other pass pawn white
wins the pawn race and i think that's
all there is to it i think we play a7
and this is the critical position we do
not go d7 instead we get our rook to the
open file and threaten patrick mate and
this overwhelms black's defenses okay so
g5 that's probably a more
resilient defense than what we initially
thought which was king e8 and again we
have to be very careful
now we could give this check on b8 but
after king g7 i feel like we've wasted
a major trump card here
i think we should find a way to keep
this king on f8 until we absolutely need
to check to check in so
what could be the logic here well first
of all if we could get this rook away
from a7 if we could get this rook let's
say in this position black were to
capture the pawn on a6 well then it
would be pretty easy we would give a
check on b8 the king would be forced to
move away and then we would go d7 and on
the next move d8 queen
so the question is can we get that rook
away from a7 well we sure can we can go
rook whoops no not not rook c7 we can go
rook b7
if the rook comes back to a8
then i think we just go a7
and then we go d7 that's totally
overwhelming so after rook b7 black has
to take on a6 but then we give that
check on b8 after king g7 we simply push
d7 the promotion is unstoppable black
will have to give up his rook i think
the solution is rook b7 there it is
v8 check
d7 and white winds so
the calculation aspect here is not that
difficult i think finding the move rook
be to seeing the bigger picture that is
very important remember even though
technically black doesn't have all three
pawns on the back rank black's back rank
is still weak
the weak back rank can be also caused by
your pieces controlling the escape
squares of the king and weak back ranks
uh work really well with pass pawns so
you can sort of use the threat of
background checkmate to distract your
opponent's rook and remember you only
need to promote one of your puns so it's
important not to cling
too sentimentally to both of your
passers here
and those were some exercises on a very
high level most of them were 25 2600
range but i think they were still
sufficiently tricky we got a couple of
doozies and um i really enjoyed solving
those so um i hope you enjoyed this
little foray into master level exercises
hopefully as you were able to see
they are solvable uh it's you know
they're still exercises that often can
be cracked with simple logic sometimes
they are very simple like that one where
the queen had to take the night as long
as you're familiar with a couple of
semi-advanced tactical ideas you're able
to visualize the board three four moves
in advance and you're able to have the
patience to often resist tempting moves
that's what sometimes makes these
problems as tricky as they are
you should be well equipped to try your
hand even at these difficult problems
hope you enjoyed the video and i'll see
you very soon in the next video